succession's cinematography is stunning
lively engaging and full of flaws it's
littered with imprecise framings
characters who block other characters
and occasionally awkward focus polls
these are all things that in the world
of formal film or tv styling especially
the kind of tv with the prestige budget
afforded by hbo would be totally
unacceptable cinematography they would
require another take or just be cut out
by editors but within the visual
language and the grammar that succession
has adopted and built for itself not
only are these elements not flaws but
they actively add to the experience of
watching the show this video is
sponsored by mubi
succession is one of the most engaging
and entertaining shows on tv right now
it's a show that could easily be
visually dry and repetitive if you think
about what most of the scenes in the
show are they're essentially the same
two people get in a room and talk three
people get in a room and talk four five
seven succession is literally a show
about people standing around and talking
i could see us collaborating oh yeah but
not only does the show keep your
attention many of these conversations
feel tense and exciting it's also a show
about a bunch of terrible people many of
whom aren't very sympathetic and yet for
better or worse you find yourself
getting engrossed in their drama why
have i got it right
look at this moment from the show shiv
and logan roy are having a private
conversation that is interrupted by
jerry pay close attention to how the
camera responds
you are smart
excuse me i'm sorry to interrupt just
wanted to
ask you something about the procedures
you get the sense from the way the
camera moves that it's not just logan
who is caught off guard by this
interruption it's almost as if the
camera has been caught off guard as well
it seems unprepared to capture jerry's
lines and unsure if it should try to or
stay on logan for his reaction imagine a
game say you hand a camera to someone
and tell them to film a scene and then
you show only that footage to someone
else afterwards what kinds of things do
you think that person might be able to
tell about the camera person who shot
the footage could they get a sense of
their interests personality and their
involvement in the scene just from the
way the camera person shot the scene
one of my favorite documentaries
explores this very question the
documentary assembles footage shot for a
variety of different documentaries but
all of it is shot by the same camera
person and over the course of the film
you start to get a feeling for who the
person is behind the lens it's a vague
impression of course there's a lot
you'll never learn about the personality
of a camera operator just from the way
they operate a camera but there are
definitely elements of personality that
come through and that are revealed
through how they operate the camera
given a scene to shoot which characters
or elements of that scene does the
camera operator find most important when
do they zoom in closer to better capture
a line these things tell you about what
the camera person finds important and
interesting so what if you use this idea
to your advantage in a film or a show to
craft a character that exists not
consciously in the story that's on
screen but a character that sits in the
unconscious mind of the viewer a
character that aids in the telling of
the story
surprise
great excellent wonderful go ahead
hello hi
okay okay give me a room
the style of cinematography that
succession uses isn't new
the pilot of succession is titled
celebration which is a reference to the
1997 danish film festen or the
celebration in english festen directed
by thomas vinderberg was the first film
in the dogma 95 movement a movement that
employed handheld camera work and an
approach to filmmaking that attempted to
mimic the conditions of documentary
filmmaking succession takes cues from
dogma 95 cinema verite and other styles
that attempt to mimic documentary style
techniques in creating fictional stories
in succession even though the characters
never acknowledge the camera and the
show isn't meant to be a mockumentary
the scenes are still shot as if the
camera operators are actually in the
room with the characters attempting to
capture things the way they would if
they were real events for example the
position of the cameras in succession is
different than it would be in a more
traditionally shot show when you're
shooting a more formal narrative work
you can just put the camera directly
between characters and they pretend it
isn't there but when filming a real
event in an observational documentary
style the cameras are forced to the
sidelines the camera operators can't or
don't want to get in the way and so they
end up looking in around people in the
room to try to get the best view the
succession camera operators use that
same approach even though they wouldn't
have to and sometimes the result is less
than ideal compositions if you look at a
conversation between two people in a
more formally styled show you'll notice
that characters are often framed so that
they're equal distance apart a medium
shot will be matched with a similarly
framed medium shot and you'll almost
never see this kind of precision in
succession but it's the visibility of
these very flaws and imprecisions that
make us feel as if the cameras are
actually present in the room creating a
sense of realism but for succession this
observational style isn't just about
creating an impression of realism the
style and way of shooting actually
serves an important purpose in the
audience's engagement with the show if
it feels like the cameras are actually
in the room it also feels like there's
an actual person operating them in that
room they're not just objective floating
observers where they look and how they
move has a subjective motivation and
personality to it this creates the
opportunity for the character of the
camera and the person operating it to
express itself but what is that
character
i want to be sitting at that table
hey hey
listen to me
you are sitting at the table
succession is about the schemes
machinations and power plays of the
members of the roy family as they each
try to achieve what they want hey you
know i wanted to talk to you about tom
he thinks he might be ready for the
parks you know globally it's like a game
they have strategies and they talk about
making plays the board of this game are
these spaces conversations between two
or more characters often in these
situations the character's goal is to
accomplish what they want while hiding
their true intention or motivations got
a pitch tom
everything rests on what you're about to
say
oh wait a minute though i didn't hear so
would he stay on as the head of news
oh king of edible leaves his majesty the
spinach
this is where the show's wonderful and
clever writing comes in the actual lines
and words characters are saying are
often meaningless and the real meaning
is hidden in subtext but here's where
the show gets really interesting all the
characters and the players know that
they're all playing this game i want you
to speak freely
what
so for each character in addition to
trying to accomplish what they want
while hiding their true motive they're
also constantly trying to understand
what the other character's hidden
motives are reactions subtle facial
expressions and body language are all
clues that the characters and the
audience can use to try to understand
what the characters really want or
really mean
that's uh that's kind of gone
thank you and
we'll bear it in mind
yeah so i uh these are the things that
reveal their true hand so here's where
it all comes together by adopting an
observational style succession allows
the perspective of the show to be that
of someone in the room at the table in
the same way the characters in the
scenes are scanning the faces of other
characters looking for clues that betray
their real intentions so are the viewers
and so are the camera operators filming
the scenes part of the character of the
camera in succession is that it doesn't
know who's going to say what or when
marcia so so tell me you you grew up in
beirut what was that like the camera
doesn't move into position before a
reaction or a line it responds actively
to the scene as it's unfolding look i
just uh i think there's
the business the journalistic values
there's a lot of admirers in this family
that's all the producers of the show go
to extensive lengths to try to create
this effect naturally they'll set up
scenes without any blocking just
allowing actors to walk stand and move
how they want often shooting their
rehearsals so that compositions
reactions and lines have to be found as
they happen and the camera operators are
also talented enough to do some subtle
acting of their own in how they move the
camera even if they know a character is
going to speak they're actively creating
the illusion that they're reacting live
and it's through this that the character
of the camera comes alive as our proxy
with the fact that i'm even having to
ask think about the pop zoom though
sometimes especially early in season 1
it's a bit overused it's a good example
of what we're talking about in a more
formally stylized show if you wanted to
get closer to a character for an
important line or reaction you get a
separate take move the camera closer or
frame tighter with a zoom and then you'd
transition from the wider shot to the
tighter shot with the edit or you'd use
a dolly and push in closer there's an
objectivity to cutting closer or
dollying in because it's not happening
in the moment it's orchestrated by the
invisible hand of the storyteller so
cutting closer helps subtly communicate
to the audience that something important
is about to happen but with the
character of the camera in mind the pop
zoom becomes not an objective signifier
that something important is about to
happen but a subjective signifier that
the camera person expected something
important is going to happen or just
wants a closer look the audience and the
camera operator are just looking to a
character to try to see how they're
reacting or expecting them to say
something important sometimes they do
but sometimes their non-reaction says
just as much your brother's right got it
as the audience through the camera
operator as our proxy we step into the
room scanning faces leaning in closer
for a better look we're playing the game
that the characters are playing it
involves us in the drama and the person
behind the camera knows the dramatic and
emotional tension of that scene and is
just as invested as us and how they
shoot the scene reflects that for
example in this moment oh well that just
screams bye bye bye
i i'm kidding i guess where logan walks
away but the camera operator chooses to
stay on shiv because they're more
interested in capturing her reaction to
what he just said there's a psychology
of the character of the camera operator
here that reveals knowledge and
investment in the drama and the conflict
that's happening on screen lingering on
shiv like this as logan walks away is a
very different effect from just cutting
to a close-up of shiv for her reaction i
should say the cool thing about all this
is that it happens on a subconscious
level for the viewer the idea here is
not that you're watching the show and
thinking about the camera and the camera
operators as a literal character but the
fingerprints of that character are there
nonetheless and they impact the way you
perceive the scene subconsciously
if you watch the show closely you'll
notice that they don't always stick to
this subjective observational style
strictly and that's the beautiful thing
about film language once you've
established norms for a show or a film
you can break those norms to create
contrast for a specific impact you'll
notice that the energy of the cameras
often matches the energy of the scenes
when the family is frantically
scrambling trying to say the right thing
and pull off their plays the cameras
scramble and search and dive around as
well
but in more stable scenes where the
characters feel safe or in control the
camera calms down settles in and
stabilizes at times the cameras do use
more smooth precise movements dollies or
even slow motion and these moments in
contrast to the frenetic handheld camera
movement in the other scenes can be very
powerful in building tension in the
episode turn haven there's a build up
towards shiv making a mistake and rashly
doing something she knows is a bad idea
and the cinematographers build towards
that moment with this subtle dolly zoom
this shot stands in contrast to the rest
of the shots from the scene and when it
hits you know something big is coming
this is what's so beautiful to me about
film grammar and language modern
audiences have absorbed so much media in
so many different styles each which have
their own grammar and smart directors
and cinematographers can choose the one
that best fits their story but then they
can also mix and match elements from
other styles within the story to achieve
a desired outcome succession might have
a lot of what we'd technically consider
visual flaws in other contexts but with
what the show is trying to achieve they
serve a masterful role in helping tell
the story and they make the audience
more interested and absorbed in what's
happening on screen the show is far from
the first to employ a subjective
observational styling but i think it's
one of the most effective that i've seen
and how it uses that style to its
benefit creating a character with the
camera that gives the viewer a seat at
the table
[Music]
earlier i talked about how elements of
succession style were inspired by the
danish film festen i find this to be
true in a lot of cases often stylistic
developments in american cinema or tv
can be traced back to stylistic
developments in international cinema so
one of the best ways to expand your view
of what's possible with film style and
form is to watch more international
cinema and the best place i've found to
do that on the internet is mubi mubi is
a hand curated streaming service with an
amazing selection of international art
house and classic film and there's
always something interesting there to
discover so what i recommend you do is
give me a try for free and just check
something out that looks interesting to
you and i guarantee you it's going to be
an interesting experience of learning
about the possibilities of film style
and form and just seeing something
unique and truly original you can get an
extended 30-day free trial by going to
mubi.com thomasflight recently while
browsing the site i came across scenes
with beans which is a 1970 hungarian
short film where an alien probe is
observing a bean world and it was
delightful and fascinating to watch and
mubi is the only streaming service where
you're gonna stumble across this kind of
thing click the link in the description
that's mubi.com
thomasflight or click the link on the
screen for your extended 30-day free
trial of mubi
[Music]
if you want more insight into what i
watch every month in my patreon podcast
i give quick spoiler free reviews of
every movie that i watch get access to
this and support my channel when you
sign up to become a patron at
patreon.com thomasflight